five spots around the world guaranteed
to get you drunk
a French city complete with an ax dilek
medieval historic district the buildings
share a dark smoky color and that's
because of the vapor exuded from barrels
containing the world's most famous
brandy locals call it the elixir of
angels number five on our list cognac in
western France there are countless
imitations but the original remains
unsurpassed in terms of quality and
flavor ninety-seven percent of cognac
production is sold abroad it's a
picturesque hilltop village in
northwestern Italy with only 800
residents but the name alone tantalizes
the taste buds of wine lovers the world
over number 4 barolo both the village
and the wine for centuries it was the
favoured dinner drink of Italian royalty
getting rise to its aptly named slogan
the wine of kings and the king of wines
speaking of which you might think
Germany produces the king of beers and
you'd be wrong that refreshing golden
liquid we call pilsner was first brewed
in the town it's named for Helen in the
Czech Republic it captures the number
three spot on our list but Germany can
claim some credit for pilsner it was
first brewed by a Bavarian beer maker
and further south we have the birthplace
of another of the world's great beers
would vice it comes in at number two on
our list of course we all know Budweiser
and then there is Budweiser one is a
global American brand the other simply
the best beer on the planet and if you
can't get the original you'll just have
to grin and spirit this village in
southern France was once a papal summer
residence and many a wine connoisseur
believe it's the reason God invented
France in the first place our number one
spot that's guaranteed to make you tipsy
chateauneuf-du-pape but be warned too
much tasting of this papal wine could
leave you poor as a church mouse